now you know holidays and hosting they
go hand in hand so back to share some
holiday must-haves entertaining expert
Paul Zahn thanks to tailor-made
productions for sponsoring this segment
Paul welcome back thanks for having me
I'm loving this fall look thank you
let's get into some fall drinks a
delicious pairing of some apple pie and
whiskey oh my gosh we have a delicious
apple pie here and then we have some
Knob Creek bourbon so Knob Creek was
created by Booker no who's an icon in
the spirits industry who wanted to
create a bourbon that hearkened back to
pre-prohibition era bourbon so we
created Knob Creek aged in American Oak
for that nice toasted almond that goes
perfectly with the apple pie how do you
feel then we have some rye we have some
Knob Creek rise so that's got a little
bit more spice to it so that could make
a nice Manhattan or anything like that
so again show up to any holiday party
with this pairing and you'll win you'll
win people absolutely yes show up with a
drink and apple pie for me and I'm
definitely your friend are you hosting
friendsgiving at all um hopefully
hopefully I haven't planned again we're
gonna do it all right what's next next
up we have a wonderful item here from
Blissey so blissy is a pillowcase that
is a game change or pick it up it is 100
Mulberry silk it's like butter so it's
hypoallergenic it's cooling it's going
to help with the hair it's going to help
with wrinkles it's super soft and we
have a dream set here so the dream set
has a skinny scrunchie a regular
scrunchie and eye mask so you can sleep
in in a pillowcase and then we have the
pillowcase 80 000 um verified review
five star reviews on this one so this is
a great gift for I don't know maybe a
co-host on Las Vegas now maybe no I know
blissy very well and like you said it's
great for the hair like butter natural
hair yeah it's like yeah silk pillow
okay next up we have a spiked stocking
stuffer with some on the Rocks cocktail
so on the rock stars premium craft
cocktails made by some of the top
mixologists around the country and we
have the espresso Martini because it is
that time of year so um it's all there
it's everybody's loving this everyone's
Loving You espresso martini and they
also have my Thai old-fashioned they
have so many different on the Rocks
cocktails that are perfect to show up to
a soiree what do you think this idea
this is cute very cheap easy you just
shake it and pour it into a glass and
voila espresso martini and then from
Chic to tart yeah
again if you show up to any holiday
Soiree with a bottle of Patron Silver
people are going to love you so we know
Patron is the world's first Ultra
Premium a tequila it's 100 blue Weber
Agave whether you're doing a pomegranate
margarita an apple cider Margarita it's
the perfect tequila for that it has that
wonderful roasted um agave with a little
Citrus and peppery on the end and it's
absolutely delicious and they also have
Alto Patron now which is like their
Prestige tequila it's extra Anejo with a
little Reposado and a little more Anejo
and it's like you know luxury in a glass
we love that I love listening to you
talk about these things you know you
know and it also means the heights yeah
because Patron grows there Ave at the
highest points on Jalisco Mexico so get
that nice sweet Agave see I'm just
giving you all the spirituality do you
should you just go ahead and create your
own no do you have all this knowledge
maybe maybe if you will you partner with
me uh yeah okay we got this we got this
online as long as I can take the silk
pillow we'll need to sleep we'll need to
sleep where can people find you and get
more information you can follow me on
Instagram at paulzon thank you Paul it's
always a pleasure having you cannot send
it to you all right